Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain a Chinese action film called
“Kung Fu Chefs”. Watch out and take care!
Wong Ping Yee works as a chef in a village in
China. He is also the bearer of the Dragon Head
Cleaver, a symbol of power to his clan. Everyone
from the clan knows and respects him, much to his
nephew Wong Kai Joe’s annoyance. Kai Joe believes
that he should be the rightful owner of the sacred
cleaver since his father was the last owner. One
day, Ping Yee and his clan are hired to work for a
huge gathering organised for the higher officials
of the village. Ping Yee’s disciple accidentally
burns the pork, which was supposed to be the main
dish. He scolds the guy and takes it upon himself
to slaughter and cook the pig in less than thirty
minutes. Using the sacred cleaver, he cuts
the pig with precision in only a few seconds.
Half an hour later, the dish is ready and to
be served. Ping Yee adds some salt to the dish
as a finishing touch, unknown that his disciple
has mixed a drug in it under Kai Joe’s order.
The dish is arranged beautifully and served to
the guests. Soon, they start to fall down because
of the drug and the blame falls upon Ping Yee’s
cooking. He realizes what his disciple has done
and asks him for the reason. The guy pushes him
aside and runs away, scared of being caught. Ping
Yee runs behind him but is stopped by a group
of men who accuse him of trying to poison them.
Besides being a cook, Ping Yee is
also an excellent martial artist.
He single-handedly takes on the group of men
and defeats them all. At last, he finally
catches his disciple and is about to hit him
with a cleaver when his associate stops him.
He belittles Ping Yee for trying to blame others
for his mistake. Before Ping Yee can explain
himself, he is kicked out of the village, deemed
unworthy to be the owner of the dragon cleaver.
Somewhere else, in the school of martial arts
and cooking, a teacher organizes a competition
between his students. He announces that the
one who can put the school’s emblem back to its
original place will receive a special gift.
The students go crazy to get the emblem and start
fighting each other. One of them named Lung Kin Yat climbs
on top of the tables, kicks the others away,
and acquires it. But the others attack him before
he can put the emblem back. Amidst the chaos,
the emblem lands on the teacher’s hand and the
students attack him as well. During a chase,
Kin Yat gets his hands on the emblem and puts
it back on the platform without anyone seeing
him. During the lunch break, the teacher comes
to the cafeteria looking for Kin Yat. He plays
a prank on the teacher and gets into a
friendly fight with him. Kin Yat proves
his talent by fighting using just a roll of dough
and turning it into noodles at the same time.
The teacher advises him to meet a cook named
Shum Fong Kwan. He believes that Kin Yat has
learned everything he can from the school but
he is yet to learn about the deep idea of food.
Later, Kin Yat leaves, looking for the master chef
Shum Fong Kwan to start his training. The master
chef works in a restaurant named Four Seas. The
owner of the restaurant, Shum Ching, is looking
for several different recipes to improve the
ratings. Her sister Shum Ying helps her with the
process but the sisters are distressed because
the dishes are not up to their standard.
Kin Yat arrives looking for Shum and is asked to
wait. At the same time, Ping Yee also arrives at
the hotel to enjoy traditional Cantonese food.
Ching offers Ping Yee some tea and is surprised
when he can tell apart their secret ingredient
from only a sip. To test the hotel’s chef,
Shum, Ping Yee orders traditional Chinese food
called the water cabbage. The chef brings the dish
and asks for Ping Yee’s opinion on
it. When he calls the food bland,
Shum gets offended and challenges Ping Yee to
a cookout. Since they will need an assistant,
Kin Yat offers to help Ping Yee. Ching wants to
create innovative dishes for her restaurant so she
doesn’t object. After some time, both the chefs
present their dishes. Shum’s signature chicken
is delicious but on tasting Ping Yee’s traditional
chicken, the sisters are amazed. A flashback shows
us that he coated the chicken with sugar syrup
to make it remain boiling from the inside.
As described in the traditional recipe books, he
didn’t use a knife to cut the pieces. Shum accepts
his defeat and resigns from his position as a cook
in the restaurant. In his place, Ching appoints
both Ping Yee and Kin Yat as the head chef and
the helper. That night, she finds out that Ping
Yee’s brother, who taught him everything about
cooking, is also her father’s student. She is more
than happy to have someone like Ping Yee as their
head chef because his cooking style and principles
are identical to her father’s. To see if Ping
Yee is really as talented as he seems, Kin Yat
challenges him to a fish cutting competition.
Kin Yat chooses a globe fish for his dish.
It needs very skilled cutting abilities to chop
the fish without losing its original taste.
Kin Yat impresses Ping Yee with his skills with
this one. When it's Ping Yee’s turn, he uses a
normal prime fish for the dish. He slices off
parts of its flesh and leaves the fish alive
even after making a dish out of it. Both Ching
and Kin Yat are shocked to see that the fish
can still swim. They register that no one can
compete against Ping Yee’s cutting skills. The
next day at work, Kin Yat is ready to learn things
from his new master. To his disappointment, Ping
Yee gives him the task to sharpen the knives.
He stays up the entire night to complete the task
and gets it done by the morning. But when he shows
it to Ping Yee, the cook is still not impressed.
He says that before teaching him how to cook, he
will have to learn to cut meat and vegetables.
Since slicing, mincing, and grinding technique are
the basics to be a great cook, Kin Yat is given
the responsibility to cut all the vegetables that
are used in the restaurant. Ping Yee’s nephew Kai
Joe who was responsible for him getting kicked out
of the village, also owns a restaurant in the city
that is a rival to the four seas restaurant. He
hates his uncle for being the reason his father
left the village a long time ago. Chef Shum
meets Kai Joe asking to be hired as a chef
in his restaurant now that he resigned from his
old job. But Kai Joe says they already work with
a master chef and do not need his services.
When he finds out that the uncle he hates works
for his rival restaurant, he is agitated. Kai
Joe’s right-hand man, Leung who was a village
member a long time ago, suggests he forget about
the rivalry since he cannot go against his uncle.
This angers him even more and he almost beats
Leung to death. A flashback shows us that Kai
Joe’s father Wong Ping Kei was a great cook,
but with time, he turned into an alcoholic.
Ping Yee was against his brother being the
bearer of the dragon cleaver because of it.
One night they got into a fight which ended when
Kei hurt his hand, making him unable to cook.
After leaving Ping Yee in charge of his son, he
left the village but Kai Joe still blames Ping Yee
for his father’s disappearance and wants revenge.
Back in the present, Kin Yat continues to cut the
vegetables for two weeks straight. During this
time, he playfully bickers with Ying and starts
liking her. Ping Yee teaches his techniques to
all the restaurant employees, including Ying
and Kin Yat. Their ratings soon go up because of
his innovative dishes. One night, Kai Joe and his
associates come to the restaurant for a meal.
They put nails on the dish and blame the cook
for putting their lives in danger. Because of
this, all their customers leave the premises,
refusing to eat the food. Kai Joe insults Ping
Yee but the man remains calm and apologizes.
He doesn’t want to fight with his family and
understands why his nephew would hate him.
In the following scene, Kin Yat and Ying are at a
store shopping for groceries. They are distressed
because, after the nail fiasco, they have lost
half of their customers. Ying notices Kai joe
is also shopping for groceries near them.
Still mad at him for ruining their business,
she attacks the guy. Kai Joe’s henchmen soon join
and fight against the two. Kin Yat easily beats
them up in no time while Ying struggles against
Kai Joe. At one point, they are surrounded by
the rival group but manage to trick them and
run away. While trying to catch their breaths,
they see an advertisement for the Chef of the year
competition. If their chef wins the competition,
their ratings will go up again. However, when
they ask Ping Yee to be in the competition,
he refuses. It turns out he had gotten a call from
his village that morning. They are asking him to
return because, after his departure, nothing
has been the same. Ping Yee is confident in
his teachings and asks his Kin Yat to represent
their restaurant in the competition. The next day,
Kin Yat and his assistant get ready for the first
round of the competition. They are going against
six other chefs but their biggest opponents
are Shum and his partner chef Chow-to.
The competition starts and the chefs make their
signature dishes. For the first few minutes,
Kin Yat contemplates what would be the best dish
to make. Ching, from the audience, suggests he
make a horse platter that is made of pigeon,
duck, and chicken. The dish is complicated to make
because it can overcook pretty easily but if made
correctly, it is delicious. Kin Yat starts
working on his dish. In the meantime, Chow To
skins an ox’s head to cook a famous shecuan
dish. An hour later, all the dishes are presented
in front of the judges. They critique all of them
but when it comes to Kin Yat’s horse platter, they
only have nice things to say. They also seem to
enjoy Chow To’s dish thoroughly. The results are
announced and both Chow To and Kin Yat pass the
first round. Now, for the final round they will
have to go against each other, one on one. Kin Yat
and the team celebrate their first win and start
preparing for the finals. When Kai Joe finds out
about this, he sends some thugs to beat up Kin Yat
so he wouldn’t be present in the next competition.
Kin Yat fights them to his best but is locked up
in a refrigerator with Ying. The following day,
he somehow manages to escape with Ying’s
help and is back in the competition.
In the village, Kai Joe goes to meet his uncle and
kill him once and for all. Ping Yee is attacked
by a group of thugs who he fights bravely.
Even after getting beaten up pretty badly,
he manages to send them away and teach his nephew
a lesson. He has a chance to kill Kai Joe but he
doesn't because he still thinks of him as family.
In the meantime, the cooking competition starts.
This time, the chefs are told to make a simplistic
soup dish but without any seasoning. This means
they will have to make it flavourful using only
the main ingredients. Chow To quickly starts to
cook a traditional chicken soup while Kin Yat
thinks about Ping Yee’s teachings. He remembers
the cabbage and water dish that Ping Yee had
ordered when he first came to the restaurant.
It has only three ingredients with no seasoning
and if cooked with the right technique,
the simple dish will blow people’s minds. He
starts to cook it right how Ping Yee had taught
him. He uses minced chicken mixed with water
for the soup. Following that, he pokes holes
in cabbages to run the soup through them and
make it flavourful. Chow To, on the other hand,
uses a traditional oven to cook his chicken soup
thoroughly. However, he uses more ingredients than
Kin Yat and goes slightly against the rules.
Ping Yee arrives there and compliments Kin Yat for
doing his best. At last, the judges are served
with two equally appetizing dishes. At first,
they try Chow To’s soup and are mind blown by
the flavors. But when they try Kin Yat’s dish,
they simply close their eyes and stay frozen,
enjoying its simplicity. Chow To goes to one
of the judges and tries his leftovers. When
he gets a taste, he simply takes his hat off,
accepting defeat. Kin Yat and the team celebrate
the win. Ping Yee even hands him the dragon head
cleaver as a gift. To everyone’s surprise, Ping
Yee’s elder brother who had disappeared years ago
arrives at the set. He reconciles with Ping Yee
and even tries the cabbage water dish. A few weeks
later, all of them are at the restaurant. Kin
Yat has decided to go on a tour with Ping Yee
to learn about all the different cuisines in
the world. In the last scene, he promises his
girlfriend Ying to return soon.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank You for watching.